liberal supreme court justice stephen
breyer the oldest member of the court
has signaled that he will soon retire
and the search for breyer's replacement
should move relatively quickly the
reason for that is that president biden
has already taken 94 percent of the
country out of the running
joe biden has decided that his next
supreme court nominee will be a black
woman
forget about qualifications forget about
talent forget about experience
joe is going to pick his judicial
nominee just like he chose his vice
president
he's going to choose her on sex
and skin color first
maybe you consider the person
second
no one wants a new liberal judge on the
court of course
but this is actually relatively good
news a liberal replacing a liberal does
not change the balance of the court
breyer was going to go away sooner or
later
and the decision to step down now
almost certainly means one thing
justice breyer thinks that the democrats
are headed for disaster in the november
midterm elections you are paying too
much for gas i promise you that because
gas is going through the roof and
there's no end in sight well i
have a wonderful gift for you
you can save
25 cents every time
25 cents per gallon every time you fill
up you will get it cash back using get
upside
get upside is this free app and when you
use promo code knowles
you actually will not just get 25 cents
per gallon cashback you will get 50
cents per gallon cashback on your first
tank
people who drive a lot are saving as
much as two to three hundred bucks per
year could you use two to three hundred
bucks per year i sure could
go download the free get upside app
right now there is no reason not to do
it there's no catch only cash back goes
straight to your bank account or to
paypal or to an amazon gift card if you
prefer very simple download the free get
upside app use promo code knowles get up
to 50 cents per gallon cash back on your
first tank that is code k-n-w-l-e-s
knowles
joe biden's got another diversity hire
coming up
it's as simple as that
he did the same thing with his vice
presidential selection for kamala harris
and now he's going to do it with his
judge kamala harris got her job
not because she is qualified not because
she is intelligent not because she is
educated
i don't think she is any of those things
but even if she were that wouldn't be
why she got the job she got her job
because she is black and because she's a
woman
you don't need to take my word for it
that's what joe biden said this next
judicial nominee for the supreme court
will get her job won't be him it'll be
her job
because she is black and because she is
a woman
her qualifications her experience will
have very little to do with it
the democrats now are leaking some of
the potential nominees
and they're they're leaking them not not
in a list of qualifications or resume or
accomplishment it's just like looking at
a a bunch of paint swatches they're just
doing it on race and sex
clarence thomas reacted against this
when clarence thomas the
senior most conservative judge on the
court
when he was when he was graduating from
law school this was after affirmative
action came about and he graduated from
law school
very
serious law student he's become one of
the most accomplished jurists in the
country
and he had trouble getting a job
and he realized he had trouble getting a
job even though he graduated from the
top law school in the country even
though he had this great resume he had
trouble getting a job because people
didn't think that he got to where he was
on him on the merits people assumed that
he got to where he was on the color of
his skin because of affirmative action
and he said it was at that point that he
saw that the value of his yale law
degree was was basically nothing
it was at that point he felt the sting
of
racism
associated with affirmative action and
that's what's going to happen to this
supreme court nominee it doesn't matter
how qualified this person is or how
unqualified this person is
they will always that she will always be
a diversity hire
kamala harris will always be a diversity
hire
it's sad
that's sad you know
i don't think
that's how we want these things to
happen
clarence thomas was not a diversity hire
by the way george h.w bush didn't say i
will pick uh i will pick a black man of
this
i'm not saying that race didn't factor
into his calculation
but actually the promise that came from
george h.w bush and his staff was we're
gonna pick a true conservative he he
prioritized thomas's ideas his judicial
philosophy over any of his physical
characteristics
not so
here
hold up stop don't put down the mouse do
people still use
mouse probably not
don't go anywhere ring that bell
subscribe
you will get the notifications for this
show if you don't get the notifications
then you should definitely head over to
apple podcast spotify stitch or google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts type in the michael knowles
show leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you